hello and welcome to El Fame a small
section of a park which is going to
feature two dueling terrain conforming
inverts and it's gonna have a general
fantasy elvish theme to it as you might
be able to tell from the title it's
heavily inspired by Rivendell but it
also has a bit of like neo gothic gothic
revival and I never kind of ideas behind
it and basically I wanted to start off
with one of the scenery pieces instead
of the roller coasters themselves
because even though the roller coasters
are going to be the big focus of this
park in general I wanted to start off
with the most prominent piece of the
scenery basically because it's gonna be
such a big prominent part of the scenery
and basically just gonna dictate what
the rest of the theme is gonna look like
and how it's gonna fit in with this but
I partly also wanted to do it because
it's been a longtime dream for me to
actually build a proper castle and
planet coaster and bike on so and I just
mean one of these forts consoles or an
actual function or defensive castle but
one of these really fancy ones
especially with a more fantasy touch to
it that this one has it's definitely not
going to be realistic and it's not going
to be very grounded in real life but I'm
going to build a castle over here and
it's pretty heavily inspired by
neuschwanstein even though it has a
different theme and style to it
in general it's got the same basic build
up of it it's placed on a rock but not
just a very pointy rock but one that's
kind of more longer and elongated and
the console is kind of going to be like
Norsemen Stein in that sense as well
it's not going to form a perfect square
or a circle but most of it is gonna be
made out of these Gables with a slightly
offset and rotated pretty lengthy sort
of base shape to it it probably doesn't
make much sense at the moment but I hope
it's gonna make much more sense during
this video
what's pretty unique about this though
is the way that I wanted to go about
doing this which also made me time-lapse
pretty interesting basically the
building is not going to be built in one
go kind of like what I'm doing at the
moment but what I wanted to do here
is make separate pieces kind of like
it's a modular building system with then
within the modular building system of
the game itself so I'm going to work on
separate pieces for towers and balconies
and roofs that kind of idea and only
once all the pieces are finished I'll
put them together into the console which
is gonna consist out of these different
combinations of pieces and different
buildings to make it all work so yeah
with that in mind that is pretty much
the idea so let's get over to the pieces
the first piece that I wanted to make is
one of the tower pieces basically the
general idea is that I want to have some
small towers some medium-sized towers
and one big tower right in the middle of
the console that's gonna be like the big
icon of the console itself and I just
made the very small console really a
very small Tower really quickly this is
going to be one of the pieces for the
middle largest Tower actually let me
correct myself I just made the medium
tower piece and this is going to be the
bottom piece for the larger Tower which
is going to consist out of two slightly
different pieces just to make it a bit
more narrow when it comes to at the top
of the building and that's basically
going to make up the core structure of
the building aside from the roofs
because I wanna have the one main tower
in the middle then to medium towers
around that and for smaller towers
around all of the sides of the building
to make a nice progressive sort of
triangular shape of the building in
general with the big tower in the middle
and like slightly lower and smaller
towers toward the side of the building I
also had to focus on these towers
instead of anything else because
interestingly this building is not gonna
have any dormers or turrets or anything
like that anything that sticks out of
walls or roofs to make it more
interesting so it's gonna have to rely
on the details of the Gothic Gables and
on the towers on the sides to make the
the vertical details and accents and the
general building a bit more interesting
and over here I'm basically working on
the balconies for the main tower it's
not going to be simply be a tower
because that would honestly be kind of
boring so I wanted to have two
balcony's one sort of at a midway point
just about just above the roof of the
base of the building and one which
pretty much is going to be placed right
underneath the spire and might like have
a small bell at the top of the building
I'm still thinking about whether I want
to have a bit Bell or just make it
general little Pavilion on top of the
tower underneath the spire but yeah
that's the general idea of what I wanted
to do with those balcony pieces now
moving on onto the spires themselves
which are made out of these blanks which
just work really well for this kind of
thing since they're really small I
figured the texture works alright
because even though it is wood it looks
pretty all right from a distance and
kind of like one of these brown tiled
roofs that you see sometimes with
castles and it was pretty much the most
viable option of everything that's in
the game at the moment and give them a
nice little rim underneath it just to
make that connection between the tower
itself and the spire and then that
should be all fine and give it a nice
little point as well since it is
inspired by Gothic Revival in general
and gothic and elvish kind of
architecture I really wanted to focus on
some of the vertical accents especially
on this building since it's not going to
be a very bulky or white building it's
gonna have a pretty small footprint I
wanted to really focus on the vertical
elements to make it appear very large so
everything from the towers themselves to
these spires on top of the towers is
gonna be pretty long and stretched out
and tall and basically this is going to
be the largest spider for the largest
Tower with a couple of Gothic ornaments
on it as well and moving on is the very
small Tower which is gonna be featured
four times on the building which is also
just made out of windows it's pretty
funny actually because these towers are
made in a pretty simple way just a bunch
of windows with some of the concrete
that I still needed to fill in the gaps
between the windows and make it actually
look like a tower but it's not that
necessary since you'll see later on how
actually fill those in with some white
pillars to make the details come out a
little bit more
now the
aspire for the smallest tower was kind
of annoying because it's so small and I
had to make it one half like usually I
like to just make one quarter and copied
that over to save a lot of time but
since this is writes on the middle of a
grid like that I had to make one half
and copy that over and it pretty much
looks like the other spires there's not
much interesting stuff going on with the
roofs or the spires of the building
which is pretty notable I didn't want to
have it well distract from the details
on the building itself too much because
the Gothic Gables and the towers
themselves are gonna have a lot of
detail and just be in general a pretty
big mess of details everywhere and I
didn't want to make the roofs too
clogged and make it just one big
sugar-coated the detailed building so
since these sides and the walls of the
towers are already pretty detailed I
want to keep the roofs pretty simple
here now this is going to be the tallest
tower and it's slightly off center a
little bit tucked into the back looking
from the front of the building and a
little bit toward the left as well
because I didn't want to make something
that's symmetrical but this still felt
like the right way to put it in - it's
also slightly toward the back of the
building because I wanted to have most
of the weight and height located near
the back of the building which is quite
similar to neuschwanstein as well just
to give it that not bit of an idea that
it's actually sitting on the rock and it
kind of goes along with the shape of the
rock and it's sitting on as well and so
I also have higher gables and higher
towers near the back of the building
just to give it that more interesting
shape and as you can see the white
pillars just to make the building come
out a bit more I was kind of worried
about the very gray look of the towers
before so I tried to place a white
pillar in the middle of it to make it
whites make the details come out a
little bit more and make it look more
clean in general and I'm really happy
with how that look turned out so that
was pretty much considered a successful
little experiment there and figured I
could just make all the towers white
that way and here you can already see
the basic shape of the building kind of
forming there is two Gables at the front
of the building which is kind of
interesting I wanted to
of four gables to give it a sort of
symmetrical look so there's gonna be
four Gables and all four sides but they
are going to be slightly offset with
different rotations it's not going to
form a perfect cross if you look from
upwards and that's the general idea but
I also wanted to add two Gables in the
front one a bit lower than the gable
after it's just to make that a bit more
interesting and really a DMR cake pretty
clearly what's going to be the front of
the building even though I would say I
try to focus on all sides of this
console to make sure that it more or
less looks good from every angle and
moving on you can already see a lot of
the building taking shape what's really
handy actually about making these
separate pieces and kind of putting them
together this way is that you still have
lot of leeway in how you want to move
certain pieces so you can like really
precisely and without spending too much
time on it experiment a bit with the
exact placements of different pieces and
even though the building is not even
halfway done finished you can already
really see what it's going to look like
when it's finished and that's really
what I like about you know some ways of
going about building it might not be the
most efficient way to build things but
it's pretty efficient and you do get a
good idea of what it's finally going to
look like because you have the basic
shape and well the basic roof structure
of the building before you head into the
details so you can kind of go into the
details of the building with the safe
idea that it's gonna end up looking
pretty good at the end just a few
cornerstones over here because I didn't
want to get detail in at every corner of
this building and I figured cornerstones
are a pretty nice thing to add to a
castle and especially because I didn't
really have anything else to fill in
with there and I don't have any any
turrets or pinnacles or anything like
that which is kind of interesting you do
see them a lot on this type of building
but I wanted to keep them out just to
make the building a little bit more
clean and just let the towers do the
work I might still add some pinnacles
into turrets at the end but I'm really
not sure about it I lightly looked at it
turned out with even though it doesn't
have that much details it possibly could
so I'll probably just leave it this way
now what is pretty noticeable is that I
put these would these wooden balconies
inside many of the details that I wanted
to bring out a little bit more which is
a little bit weird I wasn't too sure
about it at first but it really helps to
bring out the objects where the shadows
don't really work to bring up the
details and since the balconies which I
used to get those details have the same
texture as the walls that I placed them
over I figured it would be nice to place
these balconies be to place these wooden
strips between the balconies and the
balls just to make the details come out
a bit more because of the contrast in
the colors now moving on I'm adding the
very last Tower of the building which is
going to be the last small Tower and
here you can also kind of tell the sort
of system to the building it's a pretty
random looking building with all the
towers and Gables but here's where you
can kind of clearly see the general
cross shape of the four gables and all
the four sides and where you can see
that the two small towers are located
next to the two gables in the front and
at the back the medium towers are
located right in a sort of diagonal line
of the building and the biggest Tower is
located just of the center a little bit
toward the left and a little bit toward
the back of the building
which I'm pretty happy with how that
placement came out for it now for some
more detailing of the building itself I
wanted to start off with a staircase
which is going to be the entrance to the
building and I figured it would be nice
to have a red carpet roll out of it
might not be the most realistic thing or
anything but I figured it would be a
nice way to make this a bit more fancy
and also have these stairs come out a
little bit more here the same thing more
or less applied I tried to have just the
concrete roofs as stairs before but you
can't really like tell the different
steps apart and it just becomes this
huge mess of gray in general and so I
figured it would be nice to add these
little wooden accents on the top of each
staircase just to make it come out a
little bit more and make all those steps
a bit more clear
and what's also kind of funny about this
is that because I have four gables in
all four sides I pretty much had four
facades to finish on this building but
all of the four facades have like some
slight different differences and
variations on the same theme so they all
have a sort of general first door and
two windows on the second floor with
balconies underneath them but all of the
different ways in which they're made and
details are all slightly different for
the different facades which felt like a
fun thing to add in here and what also
makes the building come out a little bit
more is I wanted this building to sit on
top of a rock
much like neuschwanstein and arguably
also kind of the Disneyland console but
I wanted to make it a really steep
rocking rock and not just make it come
out of the foliage a bit but really make
it jump out of the general environments
and instead of just having a foundation
underneath the walls like you would
commonly see with consoles I figured
that would be a bit boring and so to
make the console jump are a bit more
from the rock that it's standing on I
wanted to have this walkway alongside
the entire side which functionally is a
good way to actually provide the
entrance into the entrance of the
building in the front here but it also
makes sure that the console can kind of
loom over the rock which is going to
stand on top of because these brick
parts will slightly hang over the very
steep cliff faces that the console is
going to stand on top of I did change
them a bit there I took out a bit of
time upstairs since that was just an
endless pile of trial and error here you
can see I kind of refined the brick
pieces by adding some diagonal parts and
making it recede back into the rock a
little bit more but I'm really happy
with how that turned out
and now this is also kind of cliche but
I wanted to have a curved stairwell
alongside the side of the rock just to
make sure that you can actually you know
leave and enter the castle and that
you're not just locks in there so this
is going to be the entrance pretty fancy
one of the things which is actually
pretty mentionable I should probably
notice this is that much of this project
is going to be very terrain themed or
focused I should say like I'm going to
be working with the terrain editor quite
a lot because everything is going to
conform to the terrain generally and so
I wanted to do that with this console as
well so it's going to sit on top of
rocks which I am mostly going to use the
scenery rocks for but just for a bit of
variation in the shape and texture I
figured it would be handy and good
looking to start off with the base of
the in-game terraforming and just place
the rocks over that where I needed to
get the general shape that I wanted to
but leave some of the Indian
terraforming in there just to see there
was very slight hints of grass and sand
and different rocky textures between the
scenery rocks as well and obviously it
makes my life a bit easier because it's
well it definitely saves a bit of time
as well and the rock kind of molds
around the building as well like it has
a very subtle more than 90 degree angle
over here so it really kind of looms
over the curved staircase and really
makes the building come out a bit more
because one of the things that's
obviously really important about this
console as well as the force perspective
than it plays on it's not that big of a
console it's only about five tiles
across in well the width of the building
but it is pretty tall because it sits on
a rock it really comes out a lot more
and looks a lot bigger than it actually
is so I wanted to make sure that that
rock would actually support it as well
and not just be an awkward little hill
but really make it this very steep
dangerous looking rock and that's a bit
of adding some rocks over here just to
be able to support the path I figured
for a while I could support the path
with terraforming as well but just using
the scenery rocks makes it a little bit
more rugged then you can like really
make it with the in-game terraforming
like a bit more rough and it has all
these edges around it and makes it so
that the
brach parts especially over here kind of
has more than a 90 degree angle
underneath it as well and really hangs
over in the yearbook work underneath it
too and just because I've had a bit of a
gap over here and figured just Rock work
would be a little bit boring I wanted to
add a bit of brickwork over here just to
support that bit of path there and get
some fancy lights as well because I
definitely need to be able to light the
way because truth be told I don't think
I'll give guests access to this path
it's mostly just a decoration because it
is a pretty dangerous path like the
lights are pretty much the only way to
show you at night where the path ends
and where your death begins pretty much
so I don't think I would let guests on a
railing with no fans the iaa p with the
IAAPA there we go
would not be able to actually agree with
that wheelchair people can't even use
this thing to say wheelchair people I
mean anyway you get why I mean basically
it wouldn't be approved for a thin point
so this is all just scenery and it's no
actual path maybe it could be a fun
thing for like behind the scenes kinda
tours for the park but yeah that is all
heavily off topic moving on to the
foliage I wanted to make the foliage
very varied over here also in terms of
foliage I am pretty inspired by nemesis
which also has some pretty dense foliage
which makes the area well really come
alive a bit more as well but also makes
it much more intense and compact in
terms of scenery and why don't really
see it too much over here since the
coaster is not gonna come too close to
this console it's definitely something
that I want to have throughout the
foliage and just to make that well
continuous throughout the park this is
going to be more or less the standard
for the foliage in the rest of the park
as well so bitty importance actually
that I wanted to get that bit of foliage
over there right now that's pretty much
the front of the building all done so I
just wanted to finish the back over here
it kind of went on to take a bit longer
than I expected I kind of hope it's do
you finish this console a bit faster
than I'm doing
hence why this episode is a bit on the
long side as well but I really still
wanted to finish the back side and not
leave that as a job to finish in the
next episode because in the next episode
I want to focus on you know what it's
all about the roller coasters so I
wanted to get it done today
and figured well might as well do the
back side and see how I can get that
done it's kind of a shame actually that
and for me at least every single facade
that I made for these four gables like
everyone felt a little bit better than
the last one and now it turned out that
the facade all the way to the back and
the one that you probably won't see very
much is my favorite in the end and this
one I kind of liked as well it fits him
pretty well with the rest but it still
it uses a different door and some
different details around it and there's
quite a bit of like the elvish idea
behind it as well though I have to say
the reason why I wanted to go with a
fantasy theme here is just because it's
been kind of something I've been wanting
to do for quite a long time that I have
a theme where I can just let go of all
sorts of architectural styles and just
do whatever I feel like it's going to be
fun and it's going to look good there's
just a lot of freedom and fantasy in it
and it's that kind of thing which I
really wanted to do for quite a long
time but I don't go completely fantasy
on this I've had the idea to go with
floating islands or a really big park
for quite a while and like make it on an
epic scale something that's like really
cool not necessarily something that you
would see in a theme park realistically
but just something that's really
breathtaking and amazing and it's that
kind of fantasy which I figured in the
end I wouldn't really go with and just
focus on fantasy as a building style
instead even though there are definitely
a few things that you can say about this
park because this course already in real
theme park terms would cost you millions
of dollars it's a very expensive thing
to build and the budget for this park
has been pretty massive so I reckon if
Alton Towers suddenly had a lot of money
to spend
or Merlin I guess they could make
something like this but it seems much
more like a ride that universe or Disney
would make except for the fact that it's
gonna be while playing with hills in the
area so it wouldn't realistically be
placed in any existing park it's just
still on the scale of an actual theme
park though with a few liberties to make
it a bit more fun it is kind of a
fantasy after all since it's a game and
you know the game is kind of also meant
to build what we don't have in real life
and what we kind of fantasized about
coasters and what we would kind of wish
them to be like at least that's kind of
the appeal that I see in this kind of
game and what I wanted to go for a
little bit with this build but I do want
to keep it close to realism so it's not
going to be enormous and it's not going
to have any floating islands maybe at
some point in the future when I have a
really ridiculous idea again but for the
time being I wanted to make something
that's at least within a range of
suspense of disbelief believable for
being in the theme park and yeah that's
basically what I wanted to do with this
now last but not least I still had to
finish the bit of rock work on the back
here this is going to connect to hills
at the back of the castle
so the castle was not going to stand on
like a standalone Hills Hill it's more
like a protrusion that kind of comes
forward from the hills in the background
and the hills which the coaster is going
to use or the coasters are going to use
I should say in the future just to make
sure that they kind of maintain their
speed because they are going to be very
nemesis ish in the sense that they are
going to have a not so large lift hill
that's gonna go up a hill and generally
through the entire ride they just keep
on going down to keep that momentum keep
the speed going through the entire ride
while they never actually come out of
three heights limits because
interestingly Alton Towers if you didn't
know how to a three height limit and
they can't build above the trees except
for a return which had to change its
color scheme for it and that's why
nemesis is in the end so awesome I think
because it really uses the terrain to
get these pretty good heights and
inversion
and curves and everything in even though
it never really comes very high off the
ground and that's the general idea that
I want to go for with these coasters as
well except kind of like dragon
challenge in Universal they are going to
be dueling and that's the general idea
of what I want to do I wanted to say
that in the last episode but now whoops
I already gave it away but yeah that's
pretty much what you can look forward to
I suppose now just finishing a bit of
the lost foliage and I'm pretty much
done one thing that I still wanted to do
is add a bit of planters here and there
figured I would go with that little
square thing first but didn't really
work out since I've already used that
was for balconies and instead I'm
actually really happy with how this
little wooden basket actually works it
might also passes a little bit so I'll
probably use that or some variation on
the theme for little bins at some point
in the future I do kind of like it and I
wanted to you know spruce things up a
little bit add some foliage to the
console make it look a little bit more
inviting than just the naked marble of
the castle or it's probably just stuck
out its stuck oh yeah I'm going with
circa place a few plants especially
alongside the doors and that's pretty
much it for the castle so I thank you
guys for watching this episode I am
running out of time lapse but I still
have a couple of interesting cinematic
shots that I want to show off so yeah
hope you guys enjoyed this video and
I'll leave you guys alone with the final
cinematic shots and some music
you